he's Joe Thomas the Browns offensive
tackle future hall-of-famer 10 time Pro
Bowler six-time all-pro and somehow
squeezed in 10,000 consecutive snaps and
we didn't even know it Joe
congratulations did you even know this
you know they gave me a little heads-up
the day before so I was aware of it did
you get anything a cake a plaque what do
you get I was kind of waiting for you to
send me something what would you like
Joe that I could send that really would
commemorate an incredible incredible
moment in your life the number-one thing
would be maybe a cake with your face on
it just saying congratulations and
giving me the double Khan double double
bird or double gun do you know what the
previous record was because I can't even
find who did you pass here that's a
great question how do you avoid injuries
well I think avoiding injuries is a lot
of it's you know genetic people that are
predisposed to being injured some of
it's just awareness on the field when
you get into those compromising
positions to try to prepare yourself to
get ready to twist one way or the other
to avoid injury but a lot of its just
locking but you don't come out of games
I know Peyton Manning was famous for not
coming out of games did you ever want to
come out of a game there's been
certainly times that I've had injuries
that were painful and they limited my
effectiveness but not to the point where
I just could not continue so I think for
me the decision was always easy if I
could get out there and hobble around
and somewhat do my job that I was going
to try to do that until the coaches that
I'm ineffective
what's the injury that nearly broke this
streak I would say that the one injury
that was the closest was I had a great
to LCL tear in my left knee but luckily
it happened in the last game of the
season and so I was able to
I just play the second half on a bum
wheel but I was able to get through it
and then it wasn't until the Monday
after that game where I got the MRI and
I realized that I had been out about
four or five weeks had it been something
in the middle of the season what do you
remember about your first game in the
NFL I remember playing against James
Harrison I get the Steelers he was a
really good player and I also remember
that we benched our quarterback at
halftime which was sort of my welcome to
the NFL moment have you ever gotten in
the huddle and not known who the
quarterback was gonna be like you know
they're like who they are but like
you're surprised that you go oh he's in
um well actually I have been in the
huddle one time when a quarterback came
in and I did not know who he was like
two days before that and it was the
great Josh Johnson bizarrely end to a
number of places throughout his career
but yeah we had some quarterback
injuries and it was I think we week 16
again and we our our quarterback got
hurt and we sure enough we had to put
him in the game for for one play while
they were evaluating sad Louis who I
think was their starter that you know
he's Joe Thomas the Browns offensive
tackle I did some research yesterday
these aren't great numbers but I want to
let you know you're in your own category
with 10,000 consecutive snaps but when
you go into the Hall of Fame there's a
chance you'll go in with the lowest
winning percentage the fewest wins by a
player so I'm just letting you know I it
makes it even more impressive that
you've been a Hall of Fame caliber
player playing for a team that doesn't
win very often so just let you know Joe
well I guess we'll have to start trying
to win here this you want to be the
guide around this you want to be the guy
who goes in with the lowest winning
percentage of all time you're favored by
the way this weekend against the Colts
why I don't see why we can't start a big
winning streak this weekend what is the
longest winning streak you've ever been
on maybe four or five but it feels now I
thought this way a couple of years ago I
thought you were gonna be a playoff team
and you almost were yeah but what's
different about the team this year as
opposed to last year aside from you have
a new quarterback in Kaiser but it feels
like you guys are competitive it feels
like you have a chance when you go into
these games well I think across the
board were more talented I think
schematically on offense we're running
the same scheme so the guys that were
here last year more comfortable running
the same plays and on defense I think
our defense is playing better than they
did last year we've got more experience
from our guys that have been here we
added a couple guys in the offseason and
I think they're just playing better as a
whole tell me if this story is true the
first time you faced Miles Garrett in
practice he tried to like bulrush you or
something and did you say the same
College I don't think I said the same
College but I do like to joke around a
little bit and have fun practice and he
tried to bull rush me and I said nice
Drive do you teach him any moves to help
him because of somebody having success
against you well I do watch him a lot in
practice and we talked almost every day
when he was out there he's been injured
for a couple weeks now but in training
camp I was you know spending some time
with him every day five or six minutes
just talking about pass-rush moves and
the moves that he does the moves that I
think he could do that would really make
them even more effective and it's been
fun just kind of bringing him along a
little bit and just feed them a little
bits of information just kind of from a
tackles perspective wouldn't you want to
play defense just once like one series
you know I used to have those dreams
because I actually played a couple games
in college on defense and I still love
defense because from from an offensive
lineman's perspective the game is very
stressful
because you'll to get noticed when you
do something bad but on defense it's
great there's no stress no anxiety go
out there and run around and you can
play sixty five plays and sixty four of
them you totally disappear but if you
get the sack of the last play of the
game they're lifting you up on their
shoulders and carrying it off the field
why don't you just put yourself in
they're not gonna bench you all right
I'll do it this weekend you got a watch
no I I watch every game I don't miss a
Browns game where's the punch line no we
we actually have a bet
why don't one of my guys says you guys
win at least five games and then
somebody else on my staff they bet
against that and and there's a real
punishment that's involved in it so
we're we're invested in the Cleveland
Browns oh well great that's great I hope
we can go 14 and to the rest of the way
you're not under your not doing that
significantly no you're not doing we're
not doing that by the way McLovin
did you know that Joe is a big
bachelor/bachelorette fan
oh really yeah yeah Joe do you want to
impress McLovin with your knowledge of
the bachelor/bachelorette it's a great
show did you watch a bachelor in
paradise
actually bachelor in paradise is
probably a little bit higher on my love
totem pole them than bachelors now I
think it's just increased the
entertainment value over the bachelor
hey if you were single would you want to
be on The Bachelor I don't think so it
doesn't seem to ever work out for those
people that actually finding love but I
think Jesse Palmer did okay in life well
you got the fame yeah you don't want
that though yeah you don't need that
well are you thinking that I was never a
football player or I was a football
player and I'm single wait I'm confused
let's say you're 24 let's say you're in
your second year with the Browns and
you're not married and let's say you're
just an average lineman that people
don't know who you are and you had the
opportunity you know you're looking for
yes yeah you want you want to do dancing
would you do Dancing with the Stars
still I would consider it Thomas would
like to do Dancing with the Stars I can
make that happen I think Joe I'm gonna
work on that cake I'm going to have my
face on it giving you the double bird
and congratulations on the incredible
streak that we don't know who you passed
but it certainly sounds impressive Joe
all right good luck against the Colts
that's Joe Thomas a future hall-of-famer
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience